what's the deal with airplane peanuts
from bigname comedians swapping podcasts
the two comedic Geniuses of our time
have done it again to Comics addressing
Cat Williams drama and I know I'm
probably one of the white boys he hates
these are the best podcast moments from
the month of January Mr Beast what do
you think of Janice's performance I was
more Curious how long have you guys been
dating 7 years seven and a half years oh
seven oh you guys started dating in the
year of the
Rat
[Applause]
Mr Beast how bad do you want to bring
water to her
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Village
amazing uh Red Band you know I actually
I
sorry I've been thinking about this
Janice I don't think you need to change
anything I love you will you marry this
[Applause]
[Music]
old holy
[__] oh my God hey
I had so little times in my life where
like it was just a normal thing like you
was like oh like hey you're pretty can I
buy you a drink like that doesn't happen
so before I did ComEd I was selling
Comedy Club tickets so I always had an
excuse to just approach a
[__]
[__] he had to [__] aim on you for
a while I heard I heard Joe hold his
breath when he took that shot
like
SL wind 3° guys [__] dead I watch you
know what's funny is I didn't see it I
just watched your head explode I was
just talking to I was talking to Louis
and it was just all over me I was like
the [__] the [__] Bobby has a bullet
Lodge in his
thigh
gos go go go Joe's picking his cigarette
up off the
ledge yeah a [__] pick up the casing
think there was another comic in the
grassy n there's no way that was one guy
that was a [__] magic boy que we
start again but let me be like and also
know that I am I'm just such a nice guy
and I'm going to come in here and I'm
going to be such a nice guy and I want
you to treat me like a nice guy that's
right that's righty let's righty well
don't go out don't go all the way out
though we'll just go by the door as if
you're coming in all right that I just
want to believe that I'm coming into a
new set yeah all right are you excited
to see Rick I just can't believe do we
get a new publicist because how the hell
did we get Rick Glassman well he's our
friend a close friend I think well one
of the nicest guys and you know I'm so
glad that he spent so much time he's so
busy I mean and he's found time to do
our podcast today I think he's actually
here George oh really that's
unbelievable how about what a
philanthropic really oh my God hey buddy
Wow Come On In sit down what's up dude
Rick lman everybody how are you dude
good sorry I I I had to change my shirt
I I was uh giving uh soup out to black
people and I spilled a little yeah yeah
I I well I mean you don't even have to
add that in because I just know that
that you do that every day I I do like
to give soup to black people yeah yeah I
know you
do start over what's what's the shirt
get out start over you can't do that
that's not nice you're making
assumptions that black people like soup
or
something I no but it's not a thing go
ahead wrong stereotype yes right yeah
it's not a thing you go back I can't
believe who we get today on the podcast
I know I'm so excited sir Rick Glassman
wow one of the nicest guys in the oh my
god there he is Rick what's up dude one
of the nicest guys in the world thanks
for uh finding the time to do our
podcast I'm glad sorry I was a little
late I was helping black people
move but it's a pleasure to be here I
love your
podcast I love your podcast yeah thank
you so much well welcome back yeah
welcome black is what I said to to these
men who um welcome black cter yeah um
hey
teach hey there teach that's that's what
those guys were saying to me I was
teaching how teach oh uh how to um uh uh
season a pan well we I think you're
moving black people you yeah but I got
them I got them these cast iron pans and
you need to season you need season cast
irons correctly thank you so much you're
so nice thanks for being here yeah
what's been going on let's see between
helping black people move and giving
them soup I've just been I've had no
free time
ra what the
dude what did I
say are you okay man oh my I I think I
wanted to I'm so mad I want to growl
with I want to growl at him but then wow
came out so it was a
combination you I mean I'm so sorry I
don't want to do this anymore I would
have been making the weirdest noises but
door ripped off a plane yeah you'd be
making the noises you didn't you'd be
making noises you didn't know you could
people like what's wrong with
that like anyone else feeling the
GeForce I been sucked into my seat like
the Gravitron dude like hopefully you
would faint true hopefully you would
faint
gForce like you just start singing [__]
be like what is going on you would lose
you might yeah who knows what reaction
you'd have you might be like euphoric it
might be just a crazy you hum somebody's
dog out of some has a dog somebody has
to die it's this dog and I'm joking and
the dog has a parachute on true true
calm and he knows how to use it has
anyone done that before throwing a dog
out with a parachute oh yeah I'm
probably skydiving with a dog I think
sken that's would you do that pretty
good the dog's mouth do kind of nice dog
skydiving search that oh yeah [__]
military skydives dogs in oh yeah
they'll drop those boys out of the sky
love [__]
technology he [__] brought up the
picture on his phone hey Ed that front
the camera don't worry about what we're
doing brother it's awesome this is how
we do it here no it's great dude trailer
it's a two-bedroom trailer so how did
how does that break down well for a long
time before you were there I was a couch
guy I was I was on the couch what age
were we talking uh from about either two
or three depending on who's telling the
story I guess until 14 is when we moved
out of the trail but you know at some
point they did all move out and I got my
my own room okay you should have a book
called Dusty sleigh born to crash Yes W
that's true I'm the cou I'm the original
couch Ser how would that how would that
break down at night like when like when
did you go to bed were they just sitting
there watching you would just sleep was
there any type of room well we would you
know a lot of times your identity in the
living room like did you have little
posters on the wall or anything well you
know I would have stuff just in the
other rooms like my mom worked third
ship for a long time my my sister had
moved out and then my uh my other sister
and her boyfriend who's now her husband
live there so Jesus Christ you guys are
multiplying and my mom worked third
shift so I would sleep with my mom until
she went to work that and then I would
have the bed okay but if I would wake up
at night then I would go get in the bed
with my sister and her boyfriend out of
scared like fear yeah and so I just
liked it we were all tight we were all
buddies and I was like man dude that's
crazy that's where I wanted to go to
sleep anyway but they were like go sleep
with their mom how old we were you in
the middle between them or on the end uh
I you know we'd be
everywhere I can't call it well I had a
I bought like a bunch of cats just
walking in with a juice box you guys
doing some
pal you goofing I know it had to be a
real Buzz Kill for them that's crazy
that's crazy I bought an army sleeping
bag one time that had the little uh you
know had the little face hole but I
would sleep with my neck out of it and
my brother-in-law said I woke up one
time he said I I don't remember it so I
think I was asleep but I like woke up in
the night and I was like help help and I
was like trapped my
neck my neckl was trapped we had an army
I just make sure your sister's boyfriend
being like what is this kid deal
man [__] [__] block of the year were
you on the floor or were you in the bed
with I was on the floor at that time
okay I wanted to go scatter my mother's
ashes in Hawaii because she died and she
loved Hawaii did you really yeah but it
was a week after that I thought it would
be in poor taste to come in with the ear
you know what I mean oh yeah you can't
bring sand of the beach I just don't
want to and I come in with the n and I'm
just with ashes just kind of just kind
of flinging them at people or the ear
just some black people call it which is
crazy I think I've had a lot of one
night stands you know I didn't get
married till I well probably not as much
as you but how many have you had not
that many
no but how old are you the same age I
was when you walked
in I'm sorry you don't ask a girl you
don't ask a woman or age I just how
stupid am I I've been out of the game so
long Lauren how much do you
weigh I'd rather tell you my
age little Bobby oh no I know what it is
a little butt crack I know what it is
what is it it's a it's probably
something that's going to make me take a
nap oh weed
no I know what it is this is from fancy
brought us back from Spain cuz he got
back from Spain Spain oh look at
this is this an ashtray no what a stupid
mask is it
a it's a porcelain mask is that for the
next pandemic what is
that get out of here these are so
actually honestly these are cool dude
yeah these are very pretty H is going to
be broken threw it on the
floor his fingers are all bloody does
this go on my wall these are now is this
for good luck yes the price tags in here
no
$6.99 cheap these are beautiful oh look
at this one that one looks more like you
yes cuz those the eyes are closer to
what is this one this is not lck yeah
it's death iume is it death so fancy
explain what are these what are these
called what is this called it's called
sargadelos which is um a ceramic company
sarad in Gala what is sarad mean and
there's no it doesn't mean anything it's
just the name of the of the guy who who
created it and it's all based on like
the mythology of the Celtic uh region
where Galia is from wow so did you
understand anything he just said no but
these are one of those things 200 years
from now like at the antique Rogue show
it's going to be worth like 500 Grand
easily it could be because it has one of
those marks so I could see it at an
antique store and somebody just buying
it for a dollar and then going to
antique this is a Salo I don't even know
where you got this from yes but the fact
that you have a
sardello yeah yeah you know in good
condition these things would auction for
anywhere between $250 to
$400,000 this my friend is an impeccable
condition a sarell like I've never seen
and may he still has the Box oh my God
In The Box in the P rarely do we ever
see the
box I would value this at anywhere
between 700,000 and $4.8
billion given an auction this is very
nice fancy thank you so very much are
you going to put that up in the house
the sardos this is going to go in my
garage there you go my [__] house
what are you out of your mind no way I
value my I don't say this too often but
thank God I'm married I'm done yeah how
do you meet your wife
uh on a on an app called uh you can look
up this app uh it's called field I've
heard of field field is basically Tinder
but for people trying to have threesome
hell yeah wow yeah that's how that's how
it matter wow wait is that I think it's
more than just threesome is it's like
you can it's for alternative lifestyle
whatever and are you guys still into
that or was that just how you met uh
that's how we met the whole thing is
like that's how we met too wasd we have
to think of weed dispensaries like C
dealerships you know what I mean it's
like maybe you don't know the car
business but you know how like every
athlete or do commercials like that you
go exactly hey I'm Dan Soder our deals
are so good I forgot about
them our weed's so good I'm scared right
now right dude car commercials but for
weed yeah but people cuz people want to
buy the weed from you even if you're not
the best you don't have you don't have
to have the highest quality it's like
people are buying a Chevy like if Tony
saragusa opened up a [__] C
dealership you infamously John laway
exway had on a rapo road in Colorado he
had I'm not joking John Elway Nissan
John Elway Toyota had everyone my mom
bought a 4Runner at John Toyota exactly
dude so yeah that's the that's the level
that's like only a couple of our friends
have gotten car dealership Nate baretti
Nate could have a car dealership Shane
at this point Y don't be gay buy a car
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah what are you
gonna [__] ride public transportation
like you're from [__] France dude go
that's gay buy a car I'm trying to think
who else of our friends could open car
dealerships because I think yeah you got
to find the second hustle Sebastian
Manis Scout we don't know he's not our
friend personally but you're not getting
you're not getting financing aren't you
in B what are you doing over here you're
telling me you're telling me you're not
going to walk off the lot with the new
Honda
what we
got disgust me what's the deal with hyai
why are they so
affordable they should be
affordable Seinfeld Nissan Seinfeld
Nissan it's a rogue it's an SUV but it
drives like a
car yeah we got to think we got to think
of our Sega hustles yeah dude I love it
sod you you're going to be a [__]
weed guy I got venisha SL fast
Danny smokes yeah come on down to Danny
smokes are weed so good are you mad at
me having legit freak outs why did you
guys hear that do I have cancer touch my
neck yeah dude that would be great joist
does like a hiking company he's like
it's beautiful come
camping I don't [__] know I'm gay
what do you want I'll suck your [__]
D I have a kid please yeah Germans and
Japanese kill themselves so much Axis
Powers AIS power count the Japanese you
know Japanese kill themselves a lot
because they ident their whole identity
becomes their job so when they retire
they feel like they have nothing else to
live for and then they sword that's
terrible and they do a lot of the way
they still go old school Samurai they
stab themselves in the abdomen with the
with the machete oh God people in the ER
must be like oh my God again we got to
get the sword out of this guy come on
like I don't want to do this you pull on
push on his chest and I'm going to pull
his yeah you know how hard it is to pull
a sword out of a human body with
[Laughter]
chopsticks just put a little bit of
Ginger on it when they're done yeah and
then he said something like um he I read
an article about his apology said
something like uh I'm not the first
rapper to dress like Jesus and I won't
be the last and it's like yeah but you
are the first rapper to dress like Jesus
on the crucifix with cheer litter boots
I mean you're the first gay Jesus for
sure and not just cuz you're gay but you
made him gay he calls it art yeah that's
cool but don't act like this is
something people have done before and
you w you were trolling but one of the
great things about the judeo Christian
values of the United States of America
is you can do something like this and
you won't get thrown off a building also
there's movie that is awesome how State
he goes to say again depends on what
state he goes that's fair but I don't
think they can legally throw them off
buildings in any state in the United
States of America X Tour probably like
eight states and that's it that's true
and there might be people that get very
upset about it but technically speaking
it is not legal for them to go to the
top floor of the highest building and
toss his gas off of it it's not legal
where there are countries where they
specifically build buildings for this
reason
remember I showed you these a little
while ago welcome to the day in the life
29y old small business owner and like
people hate her God yeah for no reason
they're so mean to her please delete
your account I hate her stop lying you
don't go to the
gym you know you motivate me to not be
huge so mean we found another guy who's
also just living his life like being a
nice guy he's like oh here I'll show you
the video updated max bench I noticed
strength gain physically session to
session and feeling that translates my
Max number is rewarding to say the least
I've already got my one rep max from 235
plates to 245 okay so this guy is
essentially just going hey I lift
weights I've been I've been lifting
weights and I'm I'm trying to get
stronger and by the way I'm getting
there like incrementally well the way
you get stronger just putting out this
video four things Smith machine doesn't
count that's the machine that he's using
it's not freestanding so it has that
that's called a Smith machine and what
happens is you don't have to use any
stabilizing muscles you don't have to
control the weight yourself completely
the machine keeps it from moving this
way you just have to push it up right
got call Smith machine so they go Smith
machine doesn't count 135 on Smith is
like 95 three you're gay four sending
hate from Canada look at the likes
13,000 63 for this so weird it's so
weird you're gay your gloves are gay
Smith machines are gay I'm a 10th grader
and I bench more than you 10,000 likes
it's [__] crazy it's crazy it's so
mean don't ever step foot in Northwest
Morocco oh [__] somebody said him that
hate from Australia just hate and
they're the friend list I know and
usually these messages say like love
from right that's the whole thing love
from 5,000 likes hate from Albania
19,000 likes yeah uh dude what put on
415 and drop it on your
face I'd do it with Cat Williams if I
ran into Cat Williams I'd geek the [__]
out I'd gek the [__] out on Cat and I
know I'm probably one of the white boys
he hates I'm certain I'm in that six
comedians of Rogan that he hates I'm C
there's no way Cat Williams has ever
turned on Netflix seen me take my shirt
off and like H I can't wait to see what
this
is man this is interesting
yeah you know Rogan's got good taste in
comics yeah I think we're both in it
then you think you're in it no you he
likes you I didn't tell who do you think
his six comedians are it's not Shane
Gillis well you six are me you Ari AR's
twice
probably you know he doesn't like Ari no
there's no way Cat Williams is an Ari
shafir fan probably
not it's literally the whole Bible is
like sore losers explaining why they got
why they got serving sore losers like
they sold their brother it to Egypt
because he had a nicer coat than them
yeah why you get a better Hanukkah
present sell him into
slavery and then he gets out just losers
that's the beginning of it it's so weird
and how it's like and like here's how we
can explain it yeah this is why we lost
it's cuz you know we went to Egypt and I
told the one guy told his wife to not
say to go to Pharaoh is that one of them
where he's like don't say we're we're
married somebody had a hot wife Abraham
and Sarah yeah weird don't say we're
married cuz they'll probably kill me so
just say you're my sister so they can
you yeah he sold her [__] for like good
treatment from the Egyptians dude that's
legitimately that's we studied that for
like two weeks
weeks because it's problematic on a
Surface we're like what do you mean
you're just supposed to let your wife
get and then all the RAB are like so
this is like it's if you say it's the
word of God like what is he teaching you
and it really is like you guys are going
get beat up a
lot so mitigate the
losses that's what I'm telling you the
Holocaust is coming so like if you got
to give your kid to a [__] Christian
family and say he's just got a big
Italian nose do it let let him survive
no
yeah it's like literally like the most
pathetic ways to survive is like give
the Pharaoh your wife's
[__] random Arabs in the desert oh yeah
you're right it wasn't even just like
here some here come two dudes on
Horseback don't try to fight
them immediately go to suck their it's
not my wife it's my
sister is fine yeah as if that's better
letting your sister get why is that
better you could argue that's worse yeah
so like so like the other guy's like
this guy ain't going to do [__] just
stop from raping his sister just his
sister his wife he might have to [__]
step up I saw a bald eagle in uh Taca
wow got to get that prop I did a I tried
to call oh yeah I saw on one hike we saw
an owl I put the photos on Insta like a
crazy owl like eye contact owl oh yeah
they swivel the head swivel the ne my
god do they swiv they swivel like me on
the subway just yeah head on a
yeah I saw a big owl and a bald eagle
I'm moving out there I'm telling you
it's God's country I'm walking around
going I can live in Queens or here wow
bald you saw Ari bald eagle coming right
through that's a great Rickles joke
you're either you're either an eagle or
a
Jew is that is I didn't know that well
he just he just said are you a Jew or an
eagle you know when you're you're with
someone for the first time and then you
just the next day you're like I got to
have you again and then it's just like a
week of tearing restaurant two night my
thing is though why would you go out
with them in public and not just stay
home and ravage each other sounds like
somebody wants to save a few bucks
that's what you don't want Jordan where
are you right
now where did you just
go could you see dude I saw you see what
was in there it was crazy it was just a
[__] Death Stare hello darkness I was
trying to think about how when did this
to you that if you had been doing this
to me and asking if I was a good girl I
would become very hostile mhm like I
would start punching you and slapping
but I wonder if this is what I'm into is
being DB but I think if we were having
sex no I don't think I'd like it I've
had sex with somebody and they asked if
I was a good girl and I said don't ever
say those words to me again I think
maybe I could be a dum you little [__]
what if you were like ask if I'm a good
boy for
[Music]
mommy
ask hey
read him a
story Shane I to look over at Shane to
see him be like what are you guys doing
and he goes yeah
ask I'm I'm so sweaty that these glasses
are sliding down the bridge of my nose
yes well I'll you want to talk about
being sweaty there 10 minutes left or 10
minutes in
same that's a good
one I will tell you what I will tell you
what if you would have told me if you
would have told me that we're only 10
minutes into this bit I would have said
you're lying Jesus Mary you're lying
Jesus Mary and St Peter this is more of
a physical effort than any practice I've
ever done for any sport but you know
what is what I same thing I tell you is
what I tell my daughters what you start
is what you finish I tell my daughters
that's what I tell my daughters man our
daughters be
Jamaican
you know calling me out of touch is not
an insult yeah I'm out of touch with
your reality I don't know what a gallon
of milk cost do you know what it cost to
Charter a hawker 900 from LA to New York
our lives are different I've never had a
real job as an adult I didn't get into
Showbiz so I could have a normal life I
can be down to earth okay but those two
things are different being down to earth
and Out of Touch are very different do I
have to live in Tulsa and manage a Hobby
Lobby for 30 years to be considered
normal choosing to live in Oklahoma is
out of touch in my book that's why
highways were invented so people could
drive the [__] out of Oklahoma if you
want to listen to someone who's super in
touch I recommend listening to your
roommates podcast comedy podcasting
stats from January Chad Daniels made the
most guest appearances last month going
on six total podcasts including soda the
honey do are you garbage we might be
drunk the Adam Corolla show and the
bonfire the three most viewed episodes
from last month starts off with Shane
Gillis and Theo Von on this past weekend
which currently stands at 3.8 million
views in Just 2 weeks in second place we
have Shan Strickland on this past
weekend which currently stands at 2.9
million views and in third place
completing the Clean Sweep for Theo Von
is the Rat King on mat and Shane secret
podcast with 1.4 million views if you
enjoyed this monthly recap and want to
stay in the comedy Loop please consider
subscribing to joke world right now and
for those of you who are already
subscribed and are still looking for
even more content related to The Comedy
Universe feel free to check out joke
world's second YouTube channel as well
as our other various social media
accounts thank you for
watching joke
World let it J
world and it world is wrld
D that's a great uh YouTube channel joke
World check it out out